foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
happy Thursday everybody
it's a happy Thursday for everyone
except for those in the big grapple
I just came up with that Drew New York
is going to this faster than Joe Biden
after adding a pinch of Metamucil to a
bean burrito
just ask mayor Eric Adams who said the
tidal wave of illegal immigrants will
destroy his town or as Bill de Blasio
calls it finishing the job by the way
what the hell is he up to huh
[Music]
I wish and here I was told that
diversity was the country's biggest
strength and was it the idea of a
sanctuary the highest liberal goal but
the buses came and they tied liberal
ideas to the reality of their outcomes
and when you know it the libs are
shocked never in my life never in my
life have I had a problem
that I did not see in ending to
I don't see an ending to this this issue
will destroy New York City
destroy New York City and he's the mayor
who says that
about their own damn City
I mean hello I'm your mayor
hey Eric all I can say is welcome to
this thing called realidad which is
Spanish for reality if you're looking
for a few more dams to join you there
I'm afraid you'll be as lonely as Brian
Kilmeade on Valentine's Day
yeah because this is yet just another
fairy tale that we've heard from them
over and over except this time Snow
White doesn't have a penis
the same first launch a policy
initiative that makes you feel good you
know like forgiving college loans
letting thugs off without bail it makes
you feel virtuous and Superior like
driving a Prius with a Biden Harris
bumper sticker
then you bask in the glow knowing these
ideas Sparkle as long as they're never
implemented
meanwhile the Press regurgitate it like
the goose that feeds cat her breakfast
of worms
but then when such ideas are implemented
watch as it goes bad faster than a fresh
pair a Joe Biden's underwear remember
Obamacare affordable health care for all
you can keep your doctor now your
premiums are through the roof and your
doctor says your son can't keep his
testicles
now comes the Border hey if you like
your neighborhood you can keep your
neighborhood yeah right sure no person
is illegal sounds great on a t-shirt
until an illegal from wherever is using
that t-shirt to wipe his ass in front of
your laundromat
same goes for bumper stickers they
almost always have a democratic message
remember arms are for hugging
nope in reality arms are for choking out
a mentally ill Maniac threatening your
life on the end train that's reality
but that's where Notions like those
belong on t-shirts and bumper stickers
any policy initiative that fits on them
has never been fully considered except
for the one that says honk if you're
horny
man that made my PT Cruiser the most
popular car in town
okay
saw a lot of action back there
sometimes with someone else
so after the White House throughout the
global welcome mad Democratic Mayors are
now shocked that Millions actually
showed up it's like offering your broke
friend a crash on the couch for a week
then he actually shows up and stays he
rates your fridge lays on the couch
smoking weed invites his friends over
and trashes the house and expects you to
pay for it all I mean I'm sure Hammer is
charming but damn there's a limit he
didn't even set up the meth lab like he
promised
but if you advertise that you're willing
to give away a valuable limited resource
a resource that doesn't really belong to
you then what the hell do you expect
free room and board free health care
free school for your kids wow maybe we
should all fly to Mexico City and walk
back in huh it would be worth the
diarrhea all over my sombrero
I think that's racist on two fronts
of course none of you ever got that deal
because no government ever could afford
that to raise that kind of cash they'd
need the stock picking skills of a
Pelosi
so now as Lefty Mayors are stuck with
the bill for this Insanity the only way
to fix it is to Lurch back to the right
meaning do what the Republicans were
telling you all along grow up this isn't
High School I was a liberal back then
because liberal ideas were amazing and
beautiful as long as you never did them
for they aren't real unless they're
attached to a working system and there
is no system just a phony altruistic
scam The More Pie in the Sky than the
drone delivery from Brian stelter's
Bakery
liberal goals without conservative
systems are like building a new Nancy
Pelosi without gallons of spackle
and liberal goals without conservative
systems mean there are freebies minus
results and that doesn't work mayor
Adams sees this we think look at bail
reform the free range homeless that
reminds me I promise Chris Wallace I'd
let him borrow my tent
[Laughter]
cities are now replicas of the places
these migrants are fleeing total chaos
and disorder what kind of lunatic would
want to visit any of these towns
the wisest happening podcast is going
out on tour this fall there are still
tickets available for Philadelphia where
msnbc's Joy Reid is now joining an
amazing double bill with the great Naomi
Klein whose new book is phenomenal you
gotta check it out two conversations one
ticket at the Phil Morton Philly I
cannot wait for that they're just a
small number of tickets available for
the Rachel madder show in New York and
stay tuned for news on the Chicago show
audience shows in New York Chicago
Philly if you're going to see those
clowns you deserve to get mugged before
and after and during intermission
so Chris we did you a favor we created a
more true to life promo for your little
speaking tour take it away looking for
entertainment while surrounded by chaos
and crime then you'll love the utterly
failing City tour with Chris Hayes if he
survives
come see us in Chicago where there's
tons of deep dish shootings and
gang-related pizza whoops switch those
how about Philadelphia enjoy an intimate
evening while being pistol whipped and
robbed
and if you're feeling extra Brave see us
in New York City come for the show stay
because a relative will have to identify
your body so buy your ticket today just
remember to get your Affairs in order
first
all right so
Dems I'm sure it felt good for a while
but like eating nothing but junk food
it's caught up to you and now you
realize you need a policy enema
well don't worry I have a feeling a
nationwide dose of Ex-Lax is coming next
year hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else